et ça c'est l'autre enseignement de
votre sondage c'est que les propos de
macron sur les feignants sont
globalement désapprouvée par les
français pour 60% des français ils sont
désapprouvés et après quand on regarde
ce qui s'est passé pendant les
manifestations
on pouvait constater en tout cas sur les
réseaux sociaux clairement que pour les
français c'était très bien de manifester
mais qu'il y avait quand même peu de
chances pour que ça donne quoi que ce
soit les uns les autres et bon il faut
manifester mais voilà par contre cette
manifestation s'est presque transformé
en manifestation anti feignant c'est à
dire qu'en fait cet argument est devenu
un sujet d'un quartier voilà
et en fait c'était de dire d'un
descendant dans la rue pour dire que non
on peut pas dire ça aux français nous ne
sommes ni cynique me feignants